excuse me chief can i talk to you
gil coulson is missing what
he hasn't been heard from since last
night
christ not again hey
mr wayne
hello friends i'm maz perez and this is
your weekly ticket
[Music]
we are only 30 days away from robert
pattinson's take on batman following
recent news that the batman run time
clocks in at two hours and 55 minutes
making it the longest batman film
director matt reeves gave esquire
magazine a ton of influences on him in
making the film
first was how much of the detective noir
and street level violence came from the
four-issue run of frank miller's batman
year one
next was 70 cinema like todd phillips's
joker taxi driver is listed as a major
influence but so too are the
award-winning detective dramas the
french connection and chinatown also
taking from the hard-line 70s is the
riddler's insignia which reeves confirms
is meant to mimic the calling card
design of the zodiac killer that
terrified san francisco in the late
1960s
but an out-of-the-box influence for
reeves and pattinson was kurt cobain
with reeves previously telling empire
magazine that rather than make bruce
wayne the playboy version that we've
seen before there's another version who
had gone through a great tragedy and
become a recluse so i started making
this connection to gus van sant's last
days reeves recently added to the
thought telling esquire this guy becomes
so reclusive we don't know what he's
doing is this guy some kind of wayward
reckless drug addict and the truth is
that he is a kind of drug addict his
drug is his addiction to this drive for
revenge he's like a batman kurt cobain
so if you're keeping track you have
exactly 30 days to catch up on last days
the french connection chinatown taxi
driver and zodiac in anticipation of the
batman
who are you under there
i'm vengeance new line cinema has
announced sequel plans for mortal kombat
2021's james juan produced reboot was
one of the more box office friendly day
and date titles of last year debuting to
23 million dollars in its first weekend
marvel's moon night scribe jeremy slater
has been hired to write mortal kombat 2
and though no returning characters have
been announced we assume that more
characters from the beloved video game
will appear in the sequel i mean they
have to show the tournament in the
sequel right that would be a flawless
victory
and finally john krasinski is reuniting
with steve carell for krazynski's next
directorial effort titled i f
now it's not an official office reunion
but a krazynski idea about a child's
journey to rediscover their imagination
ryan reynolds me nutty's alan kim
fleabags is phoebe waller bridge and
oscar winner louis gossett jr are
co-starring in the paramount pictures
original so with carrell starring and
krazynski writing directing and taking
the lead i mean i guess this makes jim
the boss now right
february is black history month and ron
tomatoes and voodoo have teamed up to
curate some wonderful movie lists for
this moment and today i am joined by
rotten tomatoes awards editor jacqueline
coley who has curated 55 films that
celebrate black joy which i personally
love so much because as stated at the
top of the list so often when we see
black stories on film being recognized
or winning awards it's likely that the
story being told is about oppression or
slavery and it's important to highlight
cinema that celebrates black joy which
is why i'm so excited to talk to you
jacqueline today because with
valentine's day right around the corner
i know you have some romantic
recommendations for us from this list
that are all available to watch right
now on voodoo so right off the bat hello
thanks for being here and what is your
go-to romantic movie from this list that
just like reminds you of the power of
love
actually it's a different one first of
all nasa so great to see you again thank
you so much for having me
but this i particularly love um is the
preacher's wife which stars whitney
houston and denzel washington already
makes it an a plus certified fresh one
in my opinion it actually has like a
fairly low score on the tomato meter but
what's great about it is it shows the
power of love between family as well as
showing the power of love between
couples and also unrequited love between
denzel washington and whitney houston's
character as he plays basically an angel
brought down to help her the preacher's
wife and her husband the preacher
navigate a rough time which i think is
really kind of cool i've seen the way
she looks at you really i mean
really
wait i love that you said that because
one first of all the preacher's wife
like one of the greatest christmas
movies ever like you get three whitney
houston performances in it it's just so
good and the dance scene between denzel
and whitney is so cringe and amazing but
i wanted to say they're sort of a movie
couple that i wish like just like kiss
you know when you you know you just wish
two people would kiss on screen but i
didn't want to spoil it so i love that
you sort of shared that love the
preacher's wife but speaking of movie
couples
is there a movie couple from this list
that you think would still be together
in real life just because their
relationship makes so much sense
well i cheated on this pic just a little
bit because i picked southside with you
which is actually the story that was
produced by john legend about obama and
michelle's uh first date and they
actually went and watched do the right
thing a film that is not on our black
joy list but it is considered one of the
essential uh black films in cinema and
just watching that story retold in a
dramatic fashion and seeing what you can
only imagine where there's first twinges
of infatuation like the fact that you
know michelle was the high flyer at the
law firm and was trying to like you know
push down this junior associate who was
trying to flirt with her i just love
love love that and the fact that they're
actually still going strong i mean he
just the other day was posting about you
know happy birthday michelle my my
partner my best friend and i just i love
uh seeing their love continue to grow
after he's left office and done so many
crazy things yeah
hello you're late i was hoping you
wouldn't notice i expected it you were
late for your first day of work you've
noticed that too
i'm your advisor i'm supposed to notice
one of the movie couples i love from
this list is love and basketball i love
that it's on this list it's such a
classic and it's so great to go back to
as an adult because i watched it when i
think i was like 10 and quincy and
monica's relationship i would just love
to see being played out in la now but
another thing i noticed from the likes
aside from all the amazing classics that
are on it is that tay diggs is in a lot
of the romance films on this list so i
have three questions for you friend one
is do you remember when he followed
everyone on twitter i just thought that
was so funny i don't know why it fixed
me everybody was followed by tay jinx
but keep going
it was like so random second why what do
you think made him the go-to romantic
lead and do you have a favorite film
that he started our favorite romantic
film from this list that he started i
will say this i think with tay diggs is
he's a perfect leading man because he is
gorgeous and incredibly sexy and
obviously the like subject of your
wildest fantasies but more importantly
he's disarming and like i would say
almost um i would
boy-like in how he approaches these
things like when you look at him and
something like stella got her groove
back or when you look at him in the film
that i love him in brown sugar alongside
the other a frequent appearance on our
list sana latham who's also like very
frequent uh romantic comedy veteran yeah
it's it's really i think
his demeanor like you can feel the sort
of guilelessness to him he's a man that
you want to fall in love with because
you know he's going to hurt you on the
other side i don't want to be your
friend over
wow
that was a great line yeah and i feel
like we don't come across those that
often which is why when we see them in
film it's sort of like is this fantasy
but i love that yeah that's great brown
sugar is a
such such a great film uh director rick
famous i feel like it's someone who's so
uh underappreciated in a way and like
it's just it's just a matter of time
before that man gets his flowers is
there a film on this list that you think
is underappreciated and should be
considered a classic it's funny that you
mention rick because he's actually also
the director of our next selection which
is dope which i love it stars shamik
more folks realize he voiced miles
morales and the spider-man into the
spider-verse and it's just like an
absolutely like love letter to 90s
hip-hop culture as well as having this
so adorable love story in the middle of
it between zoe kravitz and shemig moore
it's so great
she's the the coolest girl in school or
in this case in not in school but from
around the way and
you know just that sort of like
ambitious she's out of my league but i
still want to date girl type romance i
love love love their push me pull me
pull you sort of um i wouldn't even call
it a romance it's just like young
flirtation hopefully leading to romance
and it's just incredibly well done
you gonna say something or just stare at
me yeah and if you love 90s hip-hop such
such a good it's almo i would almost
call it like a must-watch but i love
that you said that about zoey kravitz's
character because i also just feel like
the kravitz family have this cool gene
that no other humans got in the world
there's just something about him that's
so cool
i'm someone who loves rotten romantic
films there's a lot of rotten rom-coms
out there and i know there's a lot of
rotten films that you love too so i
can't let you go without telling us do
you have a romantic rotten film from
this list that you like
sadly one of the greatest classics and
probably in my opinion one of the
greatest kung fu movies ever made
um
produced by barry gordy
the last dragon and this film first of
all his love interest in it is vanity
from like
prince vanity it's his love interests
wow and the lead character the actor who
plays it tamak he plays bruce leroy who
is the last dragon he's the apprentice
that is learning from his master and
along the way he is also trying to find
his glow and woo his lady love i love
love love their romance in this it's
amazing the film also has a relationship
ending
where
one of the characters who's basically
playing a lot cyndi lauper says yes i
may be just another girl from q gardens
with nice boobs and i'm very much making
this pg-13 but that was actually
repeated in another film that um is
incredible which is sorry to bother you
and so the last dragon it inspired so
much of black culture whether it be a
busta rhymes video or uh bruce uh boots
riley sorry to bother you but at the
core of it there's this really really
great romance and also great action
little pop thinks he's a kung fu master
i am no master you sure look like a
master to me
whoa i think that was maybe my favorite
recommendation out of the whole list i'm
100 watching that tonight because i mean
you had me at inspiring like other great
works of art like that and it's amazing
when when films can do that and that's
why we love having you here for those
recommendations jacqueline thank you so
much for joining us and let us know
where people can find you y'all can
definitely find me always every day at
rottentomatoes.com
be sure to check our awards tour and our
awards leaderboard i keep track of all
of the major wins of all of the award
contenders for the year and you can also
listen to me on the rotten tomatoes is
wrong podcast alongside my host mark
ellis where lovely folks like naz come
on and tell us which films they think
rotten tomatoes is wrong about and you
can find me on all the social media
channels at that jaclyn
yes thank you so much it was so good
seeing you and yes guys the podcast is
also a must listen if i was to recommend
something because you and mark are just
chefs kiss on it so thank you so much
friends remember that you can find
movies that celebrate black joy under
rotten tomatoes recommends on voodoo for
the entire month of february rotten
tomatoes will be celebrating black
history from pioneering filmmakers to
the best movies and television from this
century there's a link in the
description below for both rotten
tomatoes black history hub and voodoo's
movies that celebrate black joy
new movies in theaters this weekend are
moon fall and jackass forever we better
do something fast and we're going to
crash down anyone should never have come
let's lose the other booster and see if
the moon can pull us the rest away casey
can we do it
come on buddy in moonfall a mysterious
force knocks the moon from its orbit
around earth and sends it hurtling on a
collision course with our planet
threatening all existence with mere
weeks before impact and the world on the
brink of annihilation nasa executive and
former astronaut joe fowler is convinced
she has the key to saving us all but she
only has the support of a conspiracy
theorist and one astronaut from her past
these unlikely heroes will mount an
impossible last-ditch mission into space
leaving behind everyone they love only
to find that they might have prepared
for the wrong mission after all halle
berry patrick wilson and john bradley go
to space in the new disaster movie from
roland emrick director of independence
day
available to watch at home this weekend
are house of gucci an american underdog
can you keep a secret
father son and house of gucci fresh off
the heels of its three screen actors
guild nominations including best
ensemble house of gucci is now available
to watch at home on voodoo ridley
scott's film is inspired by the true
story of the family empire behind the
italian fashion house of gucci and the
numerous betrayals therein spanning
three decades of love decadence revenge
and ultimately murder we see what a name
means what it's worth and how far a
family will go for control lady gaga
adam driver al pacino and an
unrecognizable jared leto lead the epic
true crime drama
well my friends that is it for today
thank you for letting me join you in
your living room or in your phone i
don't know where you're watching this my
name's naz thanks for watching weekly
ticket and let us know what you're
watching this week
[Music]
you